o brasil saindo de um regime político
limitador das liberdades individuais que
durou 20 anos inicia sua campanha e sua
caminhada rumo ao caminho democrático no
fim da década de 70 o movimento
sanitário nacional já propunha desde
1969 sistema de saúde que fosse incluído
dentro de cem por cento da população
isto numa perspectiva importante de
atingir todo o processo saúde-doença
grandes pensadores da saúde pública
naquele momento começaram a ter
oportunidade de se manifestar de
publicar seus trabalhos seus pensamentos
ensinar ia transformar surge a carreira
de medicina sanitária o médico
sanitarista é professor walter 0 foi de
grande importância nesse nesse contexto
da criação dos cursos da faculdade de
higiene saúde pública de são paulo e na
fiocruz no rio de janeiro
médicos jovens entusiasmados
é pensando na possibilidade da
transformação social através da medicina
através de uma assistência integral no
processo saúde-doença fazem e se esses
cursos nas duas faculdades e dão o
início da base nacional para implantação
é conceituação e na verdade é instalação
do que seria o subsistema único de saúde
no brasil modelo é mundial até hoje
apesar da falta de financiamento
brasileiro
os seus princípios de integralidade e
universalidade e de equidade a sociedade
se organiza os debates das conferências
municipais estaduais e nacional de saúde
os conselhos populares participam
ativamente em igualdade de condições com
gestores que os especialistas com
academia e com os médicos a sociedade
passa passei a fazer parte das decisões
da saúde no brasil estamos mais ou menos
em torno de 1980 1983 por aí
publicações americanas nesse momento
indicam a presença de uma doença
estranha acometendo homens homossexuais
os primeiros casos mas é transfusões de
sangue pessoas que tinham doenças
hematológicas precisariam sofrer
transfusão de sangue é desde então
muitas mortes começaram a acontecer na
década de 80 é até 96 mais ou menos
população jovem pessoas do meio
artístico pessoas da população era uma
doença democrática atinge a todas as
raças todas as idades
todas as crises acompanhar os doentes
o impacto da revelação da sua condição
que causou a doença o que levou a
adquirir essa doença até então não se
tinha notícia
naquela época se eram vírus será uma
outra doença auto-imune se era um vírus
secundário tipo citomegalovírus na
verdade o vídeo revelado
desse jeito fazia com que as pessoas
ficassem expostas à sociedade o
preconceito era o açoite social além da
doença o vírus revelada por por dois
pesquisadores no que montem e robert
gallo hoje chamado de hiv reinou 100
opositores até meados de 1990 atingindo
taxas elevadíssimas de mortalidade de
transmissão vertical de mãe para filho
25% das mães que não hiv positivas
passavam vírus para seus filhos
o david rowe 1960 e 1996 é trouxe o
primeiro alento com o seu trabalho
mostrando que a associação de drogas
anti-retrovirais poderia prolongar a
vida dos pais
sente se manter os pacientes com uma
qualidade melhor ea transmissão vertical
diminuir
eu sou infectologista dos antigos minha
formação especialização foi antes do
aparecimento da aids
tivemos que enfrentar essa novidade
os critérios para a escolha estava
unidade ligados mas a baixa mortalidade
das doenças que a especialidade abrangia
da mesma forma os bons resultados nas
doenças agudas ajudavam a gente tem uma
visão otimista das coisas não havia
mortes
dificilmente na verdade um outro
princípio que me me levou a escolher a
especialidade foi de que o brasil ainda
vivia um momento epidemiológico sério de
doenças de transmissão de doenças de
transmissão hídrica doenças infecciosas
a mortalidade ainda muito grande talvez
eu pudesse ter um impacto do papel o
impacto positivo nessa realidade
na verdade o perfil do mec do médico
infectologista na época era do técnico
impositivo racional condutas pragmáticas
baseado na ciência cartesiana onde o
imponderável das situações como questões
emocionais questões comportamentais eram
colocadas embaixo do tapete
isso fazia o perfil na verdade isso
significa que significa que a gente era
o centro do universo é o dono da verdade
absoluta
é dessa forma a verdade estava em nós né
era tudo que a gente sabia podia aplicar
e eram os donos da situação mesmo que
uma formação familiar da maioria desses
especialistas contemplasse os princípios
religiosos né
estes eram mais ritualísticos do que
espiritualistas
há na verdade a sensibilidade é era mais
uma urbanidade muito mais uma uma
educação do que sensibilidade na verdade
isso é um princípio que depois se
transformou em uma falsidade ideológica
o fato é que com este arsenal pessoal
off de todos os infectologistas de são
paulo tivemos que enfrentar é uma
epidemia que cursava com um
comportamento social de enviesado
difícil de se lidar e afetava e agrediu
uma população em uma sociedade ainda
presas aos princípios de moral é e bons
costumes rapidamente fomos conduzidos
por um beco sem saída um beco sem saída
que mostrava no final um outdoor
gigantes da alma que dizia o seguinte
tenho compaixão compartilha a
experiência um ano de aliviar os
sintomas e amenizar o sofrimento
compartilhador da impotência diante
deste vírus roupas suas barreiras
interiores sinta-se igual a todos para
continuar a aprender
era isso que estava escrito todo dia
toda hora na nossa na nossa cara para
poder enfrentar essa doença não havia
alternativa
a alternativa era da medicina se
quisesse até os mais conservadores
catedráticos das universidades mais cedo
ou mais tarde abriram mão de seu
conservadorismo e romperam com suas
barreiras interiores
observamos tudo isso fomos testemunhas
disso tudo
políticos naquela época atrapalhavam
todo este processo ea necessidade de
implantação do sus era difícil com os
políticos atrapalhando com a medicina de
grupo dificultando
mesmo assim conseguimos implantar e
aumentar o número de vagas nos hospitais
federais são paulo
o brigadeiro hospital heliópolis
implantamos a unidade de na unidade
hemofilia dos brigadeiros ao serviço de
infectologia
a unidade de hemofilia se chamava do
total gerard médico como filippo que
acabou recebendo é uma uma dose de vírus
através de um fator 8 utilizado e que
fez com que
é e adoecesse e falecesse ele morreu em
1987 eu perdi um grande amigo e os
hemofílicos perdendo um guerreiro muito
forte
a luta será muito grande que os
burocratas na época e longe de querer
fazer parte desse mundo dos burocratas
eu precisava ser médico em algum lugar
que desce útil nesse momento o ngc em
são paulo assumiram o comando da do
protagonismo político administrativo de
divulgação e de proteção dos pacientes
com aids e com os partidos para dos
indivíduos gls
eu resolvi que a medicina precisava ser
exercida onde ela era necessária
vinculação sebastião aqui logo surge
núcleo de estudo de ardi litoral norte
ler da celma pessoal do cemin lembram
disso a gente grava de cidade em cidade
e isso gerou um movimento intermunicipal
de suporte pessoal para quem estava
lidando com os pacientes com aids muito
importante é fez com que surgissem
núcleos de atendimento em cada cidade é
e foi feita uma implantação rápida de um
protocolo a ctg 0 76 que reduziria
bastante a taxa de transmissão materno
infantil é nas na cidade tanto é que
desde 1991 não temos essa transmissão
até hoje em 2000
recebi um convite do ator paulo roberto
teixeira pra assumir a unidade de
tratamento e diagnóstico de aids do
ministério da saúde assume com muito
orgulho e entende que foi os nossos
resultados municipais obtidos com tanta
simplicidade e meio a uma organização
informal de apoio muito transformada em
uma rede eficaz de detecção de
portadores de hiv que chamar a atenção
assim foi possível implementar no brasil
tudo o que conseguimos aqui os
resultados foram fantásticos a gente
baixou rapidamente no brasil todo a
gente não é quem trabalhou né
mas o número de transmissão vertical ea
mortalidade também caiu
a distribuição gratuita dos
anti-retrovirais teve um impacto
internacional naquela época é de tal
forma que países
é que pretendiam não atender aids por
causa da questão económica passaram a
ter a possibilidade de negociar seus
valores e passar a atender os pacientes
com aids
o brasil entrou numa cooperação técnica
internacional com os países da áfrica é
principalmente em são tomé e príncipe na
costa é africana atlântica africana é
onde nós formamos médicos são tomenses
na no manejo na atenção aos pacientes
com aids e na profilaxia da transmissão
vertical é esses médicos vieram propor a
são sebastião acabamos completando a
formação deles é e recebemos depois de
alguns anos um maior prêmio que a gente
podia receber a informação de que haviam
tido uma queda acentuada na taxa da
transmissão vertical
isso foi fantástico e eu conclui falando
o seguinte o programa nacional
brasileiro de aids nasceu na atenção
primária lá no município associadas à
participação compartilhada das
organizações sociais formais ou não
cresceu com legitimidade científica
representatividade social obedecendo os
princípios de universalidade
integralidade e de equidade social
era isso que eu tinha para falar
obrigado